c'est la vie
[Musique]
c'est la vie qui change et qui dérange
aussi déçu
[Musique]
patrick invité exceptionnel entre et des
chroniqueurs exceptionnel alors quand je
t'ai exceptionnel bien sûr je lance tout
de suite le hashtag tristesse toc toc
toc qui est là c'est josé josé qui est
là
[Musique]
je sais pas
c'est lille c'est nul ce n'est pas
terrible terrible c'est pas le mont
mieux en mieux
[Applaudissements]
carcela quoi
qu'ils sont beaux et les autres qui
restent en cours à koropa des gens qu'on
déteste ces scènes
c'est bien que tu es trop dit mais je te
le dis comme ça s'il brigue wales à
jean-bernard ti jean bernard bayard de
cette manne
ça paraît bête
oui mais qui aurait couché ganfoud n'y
en ait pas
c'est une cata merci à léo et en tue et
on s'était dit rendez
[Applaudissements]
quoi
au fait un carton
sur l'est
j'avais
ras
la scène
et
c'est comme côté com comment ça va comme
ça parce que pour moi j'adore daniel
qu'il aimait tant et alors alors qu'est
alors regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors gare
leurs services s'élargissent celles à
risque in fine c'est la vie qui change
et qui dérange aussi des surtout c'est
la vie c'est la vie
je suis là à mon père va dire mon bébé à
bercy 96 bon alors tu sais quoi tu vas
le faire dans un instant oh merde ça
fait une heure calée derrière ses gains
[Applaudissements]
et quoi
[Musique]
cyril tu ressenti la victoire d'hier et
renault est là bas avec mappy rien à
voir c'est bien
je cherchais
ohlala
c'est ça ton problème ça témoigne sait
pas s'arrêter fait pas marrer crimes de
guerre civile
[Musique]